hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play mad father
okay we just finished uh running away
late I mean being totally brave and
awesome in the face of certain death
there was a nun she spat a blood I don't
know what happened but someone didn't do
what they were supposed to okay so we
have a mystery here this won't open oh
this won't open but this is already
opening there's another safe though I
guess I could have ran into this room
but uh I'm not judging you so I don't
see how you can judge me there's some
behind is bed how do I move it wait a
minute there's a big hole in this wall
doorknob is broken wait say that again
it won't open from this side okay so
somehow I got to get to that hole in the
wall but they don't know how real broom
broom broom broom broom broom broom
broom okay I can't push that box I'm
gonna assume that I'll get to Italy
alright then
how was I supposed to do there
oh I was price was all oh I see oh I see
don't I need to reopen this store
okay yeah you go get me it's hardly fair
hardly fair okay so I'm supposed to I'm
votin I supposed to go ahead okay hang
on we're gonna do this again oh no okay
yeah how what do you know we're now
that's right I don't know why the
instant death is suddenly creeping up on
me you you son of a [ __ ] you're gonna
vote thank you oh thank you very much
good rest in the bed sure why not
sounds good to me might as well I was
tired I just collapsed a few months ago
I need to rest until maybe I can shimmy
oh wow that was weird
haunted bed alright
so into the hole we go
that's what she said oh hello hot move
okay
I got my chainsaw little buddy you want
to mess with me all right so I need to
uh wait till it's a bit farther away and
then go for it
right one more step and I'll go know
when the hell that was hardly fair
I don't see how that was gonna help me
at all this is completely unfair
zom zom it's just a giant douche in the
wall okay so I got a I got I'm gonna
looking at that guy and his patrol
routes I'm assuming that he's gonna go
farther over like I was supposed to wait
until he goes one more over I guess no
well what the hell hang on there's gotta
be something I can do
maybe I could lead him in because as
soon as I opened this door he pops open
so if I open that door
and then run through the little hole
maybe he won't be able to follow me
that's my only guess oh I can't leave
okay so we go through there well then
what the hell how am I supposed to do
wait what wait a minute I can pull that
back ergo if I open this door and
quickly leave Leave leave Leave leave
Leave leave that bull what thank you yes
all right all right all right all right
it's got you got you [ __ ]
whoa
all right then thank you mister bed
you've been of great help so now I you
son of a [ __ ]
game stupid
this game is dumb and I hate it and and
everything I do maybe I can close it I'd
like to think that when I'm dying I'm
not really dying I'm really doing sick
kung fu moves darg
I tripped and I fell please don't go why
did I trip on maybe it's just so that I
didn't run aimlessly for ever and ever
this is ridiculous maybe I'll run down I
can't even run there I was I'm just
gonna cut this into a death compilation
odds not us so what do I do
can't do anything where does the bird
fly to why does the bird fly away the
bird flies away
oh I thought I had it
hey wait a minute I have an idea what I
tried out whatever you know what forget
it I tried that before it bugged until
that happen dawg whatever whatever
oh yeah that's weird
that's pretty weird I don't care doesn't
matter it is what happened what happened
out why can't I go through there you
won't pass why not
hello mr. doll miss Tahoe what's wrong
you want to be vroom-vroom
you want some broom broom in your life
you must be keeping me from going in
you old boss are you getting in my way
you won't pass you want Pasi you won't
pass you you won't pass hey all right
you're gonna get broom broom too old
you'll have to destroy that doll if you
want to go further burning up real good
and the spurt inside will burn real good
too and then BAM goes the invisible Dory
or barrier around that doors bye bye
can I
alright then do you believe that brat I
do I really do
I got a creepy doll what can I do with
you burn you up in a torch no I would
have just run from to you I think that
would have been equally as effective
hello thank you all right so there must
be like a fire pit or what okay I
thought it locked my where these bloody
footprints come from nope oh this is
getting weirder okay pushing really
really come on little girl use all your
giant muscles bodybuilding little girl
can a little girl's body builder I have
no idea
okay that was dumb thank you for that
interview it's something there no joke I
was about to I was about to enter that
doll so I decided and I got it OOP okay
if I'm here it's like a little tap
dancing lesson over here nope nope no no
no no no no no no nope okay what do we
have a word well that didn't help
uh-huh okay
oh this is just a hidey hole haha
alright then I do not like these parts
mostly because I got to go through them
in one shot
haha oh is that another doll
that's another doll isn't it's hard to
see but it looks like a doll his head
fell in the hole where to go where to go
what's it doing I don't know it's patrol
route okay you don't come in here good
I'm gonna get that gem even though I
missed it John before
maybe I'll get partial credit yeah yeah
okay I can't move forward okay alright
this one okay I gotta wait till it goes
by then I can move yeah
oh no this vine Scott I did down here
okay I'm almost through mom uh throw
yeah before I do that I need to look
what is this thing okay yep look look
but there's a hole whoa-ohh bottom okay
I think I'd be out of its line of sight
anyway
it's hardly fair what to do about that
to the incinerator I'm on my way to the
incinerator but did he not see me maybe
its eyes are bad maybe but then again
maybe I don't want to risk that
how iodine what why do you want to help
her so bad save her and we won't be able
to go back to normal why not drag
everybody here that's way more fun yeah
oh yeah someone's head just exploded
that was weird
oh so she wasn't trying to help me yes I
think I got the knife oh it's a scalpel
wait a minute
hi I just wanted to be part of your
family yeah that's confusing now I don't
know who is who contains unknown things
let me guess
body parts creepy doll holds a knife
sound moving at all
can't get to the other one
I can't open those it's locked
I saw that you stay dead Abu bream rum
rum rum rum rum rum rum okay okay do you
think I could mess some things up with
this mini chainsaw but apparently not
okay squishy things over hello
what do we have what Louie I have
there's a key why didn't I get the key
Wow
oh it's doggy its Doki oh don't tell me
that dog's gonna eat the key it did it
it key good for it
why didn't I grab it key you stubborn
little girl I haven't seen the same
point in a while he's gone he's gone
baby he's gone there's something in the
room okay get tired of that screech okay
so I'm all done here for now anyway so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
probably with this one